et on commence donc par cet atelier
autour des plantes sauvages c'était au
jardin de cocagne à magny les hameaux
des plantes autant mais nice médicinales
pardon que gustatives
ça c'est une joue bach de sujets pour s
en est une autre mot aphrodisiaques
paraît-il mi clown me magicien le gourou
de cette troupe en chaussures de marche
est venu dispenser ses conseils aux
jardins de cocagne de magny les hameaux
samedi au menu et à toutes les sauces
les plantes sauvages
beaucoup prennent des notes certains des
photos les autres boivent littéralement
ses paroles mêmes les connaisseurs sont
des découvertes alors livre moi dans ma
campagne est en enfance et l arbre à ne
pas toucher est aujourd'hui bien on me
dit que les baies rouges sont
comestibles
c'est voilà soixante trois ans c'est une
première et bien souvent les plantes
sauvages sont autant médicinales que
gustatives des alicaments qui datent de
milliers d'années la grande consoude là
en particulier pour les contusions et
ses traumatismes c'est intéressant ça
m'arrive souvent
donc voilà ça c'est très très
intéressant pour ça et effectivement à
la vapeur je les préfère mais cru alors
véritablement en vapeur en cataplasme en
infusion ou en canapé pour eux les
herbes folles deviennent des trésors à
la découverte d'un patrimoine discret
connu de nos ancêtres depuis la
préhistoire mais oubliés de la plupart
d'entre nous aujourd'hui le but de
comprendre que l'on piétaille très
souvent dans son jardin une carte des
menus extrêmement exhaustive pour parler
de manière pompeuse mais effectivement
les mauvaises n'existe pas et la berce
leur t-il pissenlit par exemple sont
bien plus nutritionnel que la viande
tout simplement aussi j'ai vu un mélange
jeune homme devant et de lire thérèse
passer au mixeur et filtrer c'est
remarquable c'est vraiment injuste
hâtivement
c'est dimanche prochain un atelier sera
consacré au jardin mandala sur
inscription pour tout comprendre sur les
subtilités des potagers en forme de
groupe et pour poursuivre cette page
environnement sont finalement soir
sophie dons soit s'intéresser donc aux
abeilles on parle d' abbey et notamment
des abeilles en ville puisqu'elle s'y
plaisent il n'y a pas de pesticides et
la culture sont plus diversifiés donc
elles seraient plus productifs c'est en
tout cas ce que pense la mairie de
montigny qui vient d'installer six
ruches en bas de l'hôtel de ville et
donc pour en parler on accueille ce soir
albert angers
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes apiculteurs et
c'est vous qui êtes en charge de ces
ruches à montigny le bretonneux
donc vous êtes l'heureux papa de quelque
cent cinquante mille abeilles
iny montaise mais ce n'est pas tout vous
gérez aussi 49 ou 39 quarantaine en tout
cas 30 m dos trentaine de ruches dans la
région vous êtes tous que c'est
dangereux et ça m'inquiète
non non c'est pas dangereux les abeilles
on insiste beaucoup là dessus quand
justement on fait de la communication
autour c'est qu'il ya aucun danger si
vous n'allez pas les embêter chez elle
après on n'est jamais à l'abri d'un
accident mais c'est dans des
circonstances bien bien précises par
exemple quand on se quand on se promène
pieds nus dans un champ de trèfle et
qu'on marche sur une abeille qui butine
justement une fleur de trail ou si vous
embêter les agents de la mairie de
montigny lâchons les abeilles voilà
maintenant trois ans ils seront
peut-être personne pour l'instant c'est
ce qu'elle dit et les abeilles en tout
cas c'est pas toujours facile à gérer
puisque là à ce moment on parle vous
revenez de montigny-le-bretonneux
puisqu'il ya eu un petit problème à
gérer il ya eu un essaim qui s'est
formée c'est à dire qu'à une partie
d'une des ruches la moitié qui est parti
avec la bei et ils sont partis
s'installer ailleurs
oui alors voilà ça c'est un dessin
manière théorique
de manière générale c'est comme ça c'est
à dire qu'effectivement d'une ruche ou
d'une colonie parce que ça peut très
bien venir de la forêt dont cannes est
une colonie sauvage
vous avez la moitié la vieille reine qui
va s'en aller avec la moitié des
abeilles et laisser la place pour une
nouvelle reine est en fait d'une colonie
vous en avez 2 et 7 est simple qu'on
appelle et 5 qui fait une belle boule et
bah on va la retrouver sur une branche
d'armes là en l'occurrence c'était un
peu plus compliqué c'était sous les
tuiles d'une maison à 4 5 mètres de haut
donc c'était une petite aventure alors
ça en gros c'est arrivé ce week end vous
avez été prévenus par les jardiniers de
montigny probable vous êtes vous y êtes
allé hier pour essayer de la récupérer
ça n'a pas marché et alors aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui alors j'ai été bien
les embêter hier elle était arrivée
vendredi soir d'après les voisins
puisque évidemment les habitants
n'étaient pas là ils ont appelé la
mairie
la mairie m'a appelé je suis venu hier
constaté chez monter tout ça et
effectivement elle était là depuis trois
jours elle avait fait déjà un petit peu
de travail
donc c'est ce que j'ai ramené ici c'est
de la cire sont pas si on va avoir très
bien mais il ya un petit peu de miel et
le plus coloré la salle pleine comme ça
c'est de la serre en toute blanche toute
blanche ça veut dire qu'elle est toute
fraîche donc hier j'ai enlevé ça en fait
ça veut dire qu'elle reconstitue une
maison à l'extérieur ça voulait dire
elle en avait construit celui là était à
ses fins petit y en avait un plus grand
il en avait construit 5 ce qui veut dire
grosso modo que vous avez vraiment élu
domicile
et alors aujourd'hui est-ce que vous les
avez récupéré elles sont toujours dans
la nature
alors là elles sont juste à côté comme
je les ai embêter hier
aujourd'hui elles sont déplacées c'est à
dire l on l avait élu domicile
ça c'est le témoin de de leur nouveau
domicile
comme je l'aï enlevée avec les embêter
hier et son parti juste à côté dans un
jardin juste à côté et là sur une
branche
ça peut durer longtemps comme ça alors
ça peut durer longtemps en fait les
saints donc la boule qu'on va se balader
c'est transitoire ça veut dire qu'elle
cherche une nouvelle maison et là par
contre sur une branche c'est beaucoup
plus simple que sous des tuiles et donc
je les récupère et tout à l'heure et je
vais aller voir cette nuit si elles sont
bel et bien rester mais comme j'ai pas
eu de coups de fils de la dame bons
souvenirs mais alors va s'enticher
qu'ont été installées oui la mairie
affaire à suivre
et puis aussi parce que vous vous gérez
aussi des des ruches pour les
particuliers en fait c'est ça il ya une
espèce de tendance est ce qu'il ya un
engouement pour les ruches dans les
villes alors ça aurait changé le il ya
une vraie mode et ça vraiment la cote 1
on en voit de plus en plus ce qui se
fait beaucoup ça avec les sociétés les
entreprises donc les rues sur les toits
des entreprises c c'est ça c'est ce que
je fais plus ou moins avec montigny et
j'ai une bonne trentaine de ruches en
ile de france et pour les médias les
questionnements pour les particuliers il
ya des gens qui s'intéressent la formule
est un peu différente
qu'est-ce que vous avez des conseils à
donner voilà moi ce que je fais avec
avec les particuliers je leur fournis
tout le matériel c'est à dire la boîte
les cadres qu'on voit ici et les
abeilles évidemment et après je fais
tout un accompagnement ce que je fais
vraiment avec eux c'est je les rencontre
je leur dis moi quelle sont grosso modo
les engagements l'investissement qu'il
faut avoir
et après je propose un accompagnement
c'est pas un vrai suivi aussi rigoureux
que je vais faire comme ici à monter
mais ça coûte combien de s'investir dans
une russe alors une ruche peuple et
suivant le modèle de ruches parce qu'il
ya plein de modèles qu'on veut c'est
entre 250 et 300 euros
voilà sachant que moi pour le
particulier je viens et je fais ce qu'on
appelle communément la visite de
faisabilité savoir si on respecte la
réglementation savoir s'il ya assez à
manger pour les abeilles mais ça en
ville on leur maintenance est de
notoriété publique qu'il n'y a pas de
problème mais tous ces petits problèmes
et souvent les problèmes de voisinage
quand même je fais en sorte que ça se
passe bien on peut en avoir sur son
balcon à une ruche
il y en a il y en a qui ont déjà des
abeilles sur leur balcon dans paris même
et en banlieue
est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être aussi
revenir sur l'importance des abeilles
ont dit que c'est très important pour la
pollinisation cia plus d'abeilles
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors bon c'est
toujours la phrase qu'on sort et qui a
été on va dire donner un bernstein c'est
que si l'abeille mouret l'uma et n
aurait plus que pour quatre ans après on
peut avancer d'autres chiffres et là on
sait que ça vient d'eux l'inra par
exemple a fait une étude très sérieuse
est en fait la beille est impliqué de
manière plus ou moins essentielle mais
en tout cas importante dans la
fécondation de 80% des plantes
que l'homme utilise pour se nourrir
aujourd'hui donc c'est une vraie
sentinelle de l'environnement la bei et
donc c'est une vraie sentinelle de
l'environnement effectivement qui permet
de on va dire de voir dans quel état est
un environnement dans lequel on installe
les abeilles et ça permet de faire du
miel également puisqu'on en parle est
est ce que ce miel en ville est meilleur
que celui qui produit après les gouts et
les couleurs c'est toujours pareil
pareil chacun ses goûts par exemple
l'année dernière j'ai produit un miel
sur paris vers pont de l'alma qui était
très très bon très floral un peu un peu
fort et pas vraiment sucré
à côté de ça à versailles j'ai fait un
miel qui est assez typique d'un miel de
châtaignier donc beaucoup plus foncée
bien visqueux et elle a assez à lormont
ça reste c'est pas un châtaignier fort
donc il n'était pas très amer mais une
petite amertume binôme m
et encore à côté de ça par exemple un
hors jeu valve un autre miel qui était
plus un miel de on va dire de prêts ou
là c'était très blanc cristallisé et
très doux et bien sucré là il ya plus
vous voulez du miel chez vous si vous
voulez contribuer à l'environnement à
respecter cet écosystème on peut vous
contacter tout simplement voilà et vous
aiderez installer les enrichit vous
assurez même c'est le service
après-vente quand il ya des abeilles à
qui décide de s'installer à côté
petite remarque le service après-vente
les les cinq j'ai ramassé aujourd'hui à
montigny c'est sûr il vient pas des
ruches que j'ai installé à l'amérique
voilà ça vient d'autre part là c'est
qu'ils habitent c'était important à
préciser pour les habitants qui sera pas
très content d'avoir les russes au pied
de la mairie
effectivement vous avez raison vous
dédouanez merci à vous sauf si on passe
à la jambe et à présent oui absolument
alors pour tout connaître des orchidées
sauvages d'île de france
rendez vous samedi prochain à l'hôtel de
ville de versailles gérard arnal
botaniste et auteur de plusieurs livres
sur les plantes sauvages en ile de
france animera une conférence dès 14h30
dimanche l'association les amis du passé
d'elancourt organise sa traditionnelle
balade commentée au départ de la
fondation méquignon départ à 9h30
et si vous n'êtes pas encore inscrit il
est encore temps vous avez jusqu'au 31
juillet le 7e concours maison économe
est ouverte depuis le 1er avril ce n'est
pas une blague c'est un concours gratuit
ouvert à tous les particuliers du
département des yvelines peuvent y
participer
et ça a pour but de valoriser des
projets exemplaires en
tiers de développement durable